thank you yasser yes i'm here with
anishgiri after
a uh game without much history uh did
you decide to play the grunfeld
knowing that shaq is probably going to
go into this line not exactly knowing
but
uh i wanted to have it clear like i
don't want this you know like
know what i'm talking about you want to
know like what the guy wants like uh
not that you know this is like yeah and
then like maybe you know like
no just do you want to draw or do you
want to play okay you want to draw fine
go into this line of course okay uh not
much history in today's game so i'm
going to
work you a little bit in order to
analyze all the other games that
are still going on so which one do you
want to go to let's let's see let's see
from the start
gracious very interesting you know
what's fascinating about these lines is
that
you can play a4 and d4 in different
orders
and bishop g4 is there at various points
so for example here
white can black and star would be f5 it
should be three bishop c5
but now there is the move a4 and you
cannot play bishop g4 at all
correct you can also go okay you know
i'm just sort of pretending of course
pretending that you know but uh bishop
bishop c5 the point is that now there is
extra option bishop c2
which we saw for example the sharp line
we solved a couple days ago in game of
thrones
but now the point is if you do go bishop
b3 d6
now for example a4 you can already go
bishop g4 you can do it here which is
very different from doing it here
because
white has committed himself to d4 for
example if a4 first
and then bishop g4 while it could play
in some positions directly or in some
positions move like d3
and then there is no tension in the
center at all and the bishop on g4 is
very interesting because it's
it is pinning the knight but sometimes
if we let's say imagine a position like
this
it's going to get hit it could it could
get sort of sort of stuck here and then
it's a trade-off the bishop is out of
play because it's cut off by these pawns
d3 e4 pawn especially not that we didn't
put before but at the same time g4
weakens the king so you get these
fascinating positions
it's not clear at all fabiano wanted to
go bishop g4 but alexander played d4 and
a4
and now uh fabiano uses this option to
go bishop g4
there are moves like bishop b7 also move
rook b8 but bishop g4 is
one of those and i think this is a very
exciting theoretical battle
and this usually goes into those lines
where white gets a pawn right if i'm not
myself
that's i think it's not really that's
one no no no that one is that one you
speak about is rugby
and then then there is this knight a3
business with uh castle
number cosmology foreign
it could lead to this kind of business
like for example the engine
your engine immediately shows this kind
of murky business like
uh here and that's super weird because
you've got the open g file
for sort of attack at the same time
there is some yeah there is some
some potential for like in if it were an
end game maybe bishop would be forever
still that would be famous
but here the king is way too weak you
know and so g4 is probably too much
so you've got this very messed up
situation white has some light square
domination but it's shaky a five is
coming
this is just one of the many lines and
i'm uh i'm hoping for aggression that
he's well prepped
he should be honestly when the guy
played it two days ago you have to be
prepared thinking though
yeah he's always thinking but
i i suspect bishop g4 might not have
been at the top of his list as far as i
know
uh bishop b7 is what a lot of players
play with this move order i think it's
levon played as well
so probably bishop b7 was his third
priority number one rook b8 also he had
to check but bishop g4 is he must have
looked at it as well i mean he must have
and now he is of course also maybe he
thought for example that white was
better
according to his notes or he thought it
is not an interesting line for black so
he's wondering
well fabi plays it nonetheless maybe
what is he thinking what what have i
missed
can i still jump out of my prep do i
want to jump out of my breath do i
remember my prep all these thoughts also
it seems like fabiano is definitely
uh enjoying stirring the game into this
type of like super wild battle
fabiano is really he loves taking up a
fight with black
whenever possible he's provoking the
fight always with the black pieces
that's very admirable but
as you can see it's always a
double-edged sword you know
you he plays under the assumption that
he is a better player in complicated
positions
and that assumption is sort of correct
but i think when you face
a player as strong as grishok and all
the other players you know
it's not a given that all this
complication but complicated battles is
he's going to win them
and right now in the tournament he's
struggling on minus one surprisingly so
nonetheless i mean i respect his
approach and when it works it works very
well sometimes he's able to win games
with white and with black
but it is a very risky approach it's
also very demanding you have to work so
hard
to keep finding these ideas because you
know to make move like bishop g4 work
you need to spend hours an hour because
the engine says first white is better
you have to make sure that and then you
think like what are the odds of
white losing it anyway blight has like
hundreds of ways to equalize
so like it's a lot of work for some kind
of interesting reward and he's taking
these chances
he's a very hard worker and it usually
pays off but
mostly when he's in good shape when he's
in shape it can backfire
of course of course when you are in bad
shape you you really want to
go towards the simple options but he
maybe doesn't have them you know he
prepares with the assumption that he's
in good shape and then when it comes to
this game
maybe he no longer can play the pressure
of maybe he forgot all the variations
already from the world championship
so now he has to enter the mess and
already he's entering the mass and now
it's already
you know like this russian roulette he
he's wounded but he has to still take a
shot and see what happens
absolutely this one is definitely very
exciting let's jump on to
the wesley versus mvlg wow
as the youtube comments say this all
theory
there yeah knight h194 in this order is
what maxine played
a couple of times in the world cup a few
years back knight b5 knight dc6 d4 a65 i
remember this
as well i've studied this line and
yes yes i've i've looked at all this
business actually for a second i thought
that we're going to see a quick draw
with king f1 king
too oh here yeah
yeah but 93 of course also allows
queenie so which is a serious line yeah
maxine plays 96 and um yeah i have
according to my notes black is
like holding i guess and we see here a
variation also for this engine
i don't know i don't think it's so weak
probably yeah it's probably kind of
forced
queen h5 h6 and white can
first trade and then get this opposite
colored bishops
this engine gives a small plus but
probably it's not much or something like
this
if you were in time to get the bishop
one day long diagonally it'd be great uh
but
uh king on f1 is still needs let's say
computer spends the whole tempo on this
but then black gets some moves and
bishop d2 is not so easy yet to get
uh wesley must be in book maksim has to
remember
his his stuff i'm not sure if he does
much questions well so far he seems to
be
he's yeah he took on h4 he should know
the problem for maximus is for
anybody um there's so much to remember
to remember and there's no guarantee
that wesley is going for this line he
could be playing one e4 during the night
after remember he will be playing one d4
there's the grunfeld
there's absolutely no guarantee what's
going to come um here there are you know
so this is the modern chess i mean
probably all the player players of the
tournament have studied this position
and know the conclusions
but none of them remember it today i
hope for maxim that he does
let's see what's going to happen in this
one how about the one between
daniel duck by the way are you impressed
with the way doc
is playing his last minute replacement
the
bottom c in terms of rating and he's
just playing admirably
right well when i was preparing for him
on the first day i have never i knew him
uh at some point i beat him uh in some
training blitz match i mean
not it wasn't arranged it was just
ponchos.com yeah okay i
uh challenged playing a lot he has a
high rating so i thought he
took some of his rating so i never
thought he's
you know like her he's obviously a
talent but i never thought he was
anything
all too um uh special you know yeah to
put
things frankly i mean we don't i didn't
think we speak of the next world
champion or anything like that uh
i thought he could be a top player in
the future but you know nothing special
but then as i had
to prepare against him i've realized
that he's really well prepared i started
to realize that he's always following
the trends
and he has a very dynamic opening repair
to our
he plays all the hot things you know
clearly he loves
checking openings that was obvious from
his repertoire he works a lot
it works a lot and the one thing against
him um
would be that you know it's one thing to
work when you're facing
people in the open tournament it's a
little bit different level of work like
you don't go as deep you go a little
wider
you look for interesting positions where
you you stop also at the point where you
think like well
it's interesting i'll probably beat my
opponent because i'm stronger but here
is different he's playing
opponents who are supposed to be
stronger so he has to stop further
than usual and i thought with so little
time he might not be able to switch
because
he has a lot of openings with black but
sometimes you need that fire
proof weapon but he seems to have that
as well
i don't know if he was if he quickly
like now on the goal like every day he
works
and he made it up now or if he had it
ready just in case
i don't know but he seems to be well
prepped and in this game i think levon
um levon did a great job i think it's
important that levon won yesterday
he got some confidence he's hoping for a
good finish still ambitious finish
and he does play for a win with uh the
neither from
the games i saw of levon whenever he
plays neither he only does it when he's
really desperate so i don't think he
knows it that well i think
it's more um he's taking a big chance
yeah
i mean normally neither if it's not a
big risk he could also be playing the
dragon by the way
the reason there is a new course on the
dragon tell me about that could be
tell me about that i haven't seen you
play the dragon yet uh
that's you know it's different there's
no skin in the game practice practice
what you preach no no you have to
convince us
that's not how that's not how it works
christian um the world you know you know
these politicians all this like
a lot of nonsense going on people
believe like a lot of people are fooled
and
you don't always have to put the money
where the mouth is um
uh but speaking of the money this could
be it could have been the dragon
you know we don't know after bishop b5
check 97 is the way to
keep more pieces correct but to be
honest i know this very well um
yeah it is ambitious uh if white is
completely unsuper
unprepared of course there is theory and
white can play it quite safe
the system he went for though um well i
definitely recommend the movie e5
but i have to say there are some drawish
tendencies in these positions
because very often white can um if white
wants to play ambitiously he goes h3
wastes the time but if white is not
ambitious he can just make some useful
moves like
that and uh very often black's best is
to uh
is to do this you know force the
repetition but if you want to play for a
win then white avoided the move h3 and
maybe he has
a small something so this line in which
course can we find in the dragon or
the neither there is there's a chord for
every line correct assumption this one
is in the night of course
the dragon course i give here bishop d7
it's a little different
uh to be honest i think at the top level
um bishop d7 offers
a more reliable approach less lines for
white more compact but of course you
trade
a pair of bishops so 97 is more a more
traditional way of trying to
outclass your opponent so e6 objectively
is
is not the move but if left gets
if left gets a hedgehog he seems to be
going for a
if he gets a hedgehog type structure
without any direct
there's no c4 either so yeah yeah well
actually it's more of a sort of a
sicilian
yeah um i think he's happy with the
opening like b6
yeah if he can if he can b6 uh also
sometimes there is this idea of knight
e5
and then white should uh well if you
were to take then you get completely
double-edged structure
knight on c3 is then bad these pawns of
course white has majority on the queen
side but it's not going anywhere in the
middle game and black has got this f4
square sometimes knight goes
f5 comes so there is some potential
there also you could go indeed for this
hedgehog like black set up hawk white
hasn't put upon c4 yet but
uh you know this i think it transposes
to one other theoretical position
it's actually not easy for black because
i've got this knight d2
to c4 maneuver pushing against that d6
pawn
and uh things get forced that's very
interesting question so if you go bishop
b7 now you're having uh some issues
i think actually it's bishop e3 first
because 92 is 95. i think this
suddenly we transpose yeah we transpose
to another line in in bishop b5 check
that's um
this is a big theory uh but you know as
the pawn structure disappeared i think
it's bishop of four
then queen 693 i recall this becomes uh
very open and a lot of trades happen and
this is again very
very george very safe for white white
plays without risk so the one has to
be careful not to fall into that and i
don't know if knows this
but he seems to be playing very fast
isn't he 95
no no actually yeah yeah i like this 95
but this computer doesn't hate it and i
really like it because i think this
yeah allow that okay fine you allow the
a4 what to do
you know you can't have it all so um you
have to allow something then bishop
comes to the center two c6
and white doesn't have anything concrete
and i think this is how it starts
so it's a good good start for levon i
really appreciate that he played in
either
i am very curious what level knows uh
maybe not the neither or the dragon
could also be some um classical vasquez
because neither i don't know what what
does levon know in compared to bogdan
who is playing
neither with both colors down the sharp
lines and we're going to have to ask him
but you know levon might have also
studied my course you know that's that's
what i'm going to ask him
okay let's go to the last one raw jabba
versus oh yeah one
other one classical yeah yeah well you
know today is a big day
uh tamura is going for it thank you
thanks for it
uh also yeah tim was going for it also
he has no choice
his opponent is playing these openings
that uh they don't even
offer really a way to play it safe it's
not like he
he wants to play aggressively black but
just his openings maybe it's because he
uh constantinople plays mostly the open
tournaments
so um like naturally he's gravitated
he's built his repairs for around these
aggressive variations and by now it is
uh it's very late for him to switch and
suddenly play the solid berlin
i mean he can try but he hasn't have any
experience at
all with e4 e5 on high level or even on
any level so
you know it's not that easy even if you
play the solid berlin or italians
you have to have some experience you
know at least and uh so he still
continues with that same approach
against the very top players that's
going to lead to exciting games but
that's a whole different like level of
play and also different level of prep by
his opponents
so uh yeah i hope for him he's better
better prep to be honest i did not
expect him to repeat this line i was
expecting something a bit more
reactionary yeah
i thought the french was more solid but
this line is also objectively okay
just that wait there's another course on
the french as well
oh there's a course in the franchise
it's unbelievable there's also course on
this stuff but it's not by me okay um
so let's not advertise that differential
i i you know i
it happens uh naturally i didn't i'm
even mentioning french
not even to promote the course but it's
like part of me now i like
effortlessly promote my courses it's a
full-time uh full-time job
yeah but the good thing for constantine
is that he lost in this line horribly
against grisham and hopefully he has
something new and now yeah he of course
was
very carefully because you know when you
lose so horribly
you either stop playing or if you do
play the line again you now already know
the danger you know you were last time
too naive
so this time you really try to have it
all nicely figured out
rajabov is also prepared but he's
thinking for a very long time yeah
excited
today very exciting games anish thank
you very much for putting in some work
after the game
and joining us for the commentary thank
you for the free
advertising space um always thank you
always harness
nice back to you